oh that's cool what's up with the get up
it's not halloween yet vr it do be
international talk like a pirate day and
i do be liking to get into the spirit of
the sea
and let the ways grasshold of
oh oh yeah yeah cool but uh you know
that pirates didn't actually sound like
that right what i i mean they might have
but the whole yar shiver me timbers and
all that it's pure fiction come on man
just let me have this in fact if you
really wanted to talk like a pirate
you're just gonna need some severe
dehydration heat stroke and brain damage
yeah i think i'll stick with the disney
pirate
[Music]
hello internet welcome to film theory
the show that knows a pirate's favorite
letter you might think it's r and that's
definitely a good guess but it always do
be the sea you know pirates of the
caribbean is a weird franchise who have
had such a massive impact on pop culture
seriously a 140 million film based on a
pretty okay theme park ride in the then
dead genre of pirate action movie that
had flop written all over it i'd say
it's a pretty safe bet that the main
reason it was such a cultural touchstone
was the rum loving swashbuckling jack
sparrow captain jack sparrow
sorry captain jack sparrow everyone fell
in love with johnny depp's portrayal of
the legendary pirate blending the
swagger of rock stars like keith
richards with the bumbling buffoonery of
the now super cancelled pepe le pew depp
was even nominated for an oscar for the
part just about the only people in the
world who didn't love his portrayal were
the executives at disney yep who
apparently couldn't stand depp's take
and wondered if the character was gay
wow wow disney i'm just glad you've been
able to become more progressive in the
20 years since that move nope never mind
anyway those executives changed their
tune real quick when depp's captain jack
led the franchise into the hearts and
wallets of audiences worldwide earning
nearly 4.5 billion dollars at the global
box office now that is a lot of rum
money now there's been a lot of
discussion over the last two decades
around whether captain jack's antics
were the result of an underestimated
genius level intellect hidden under that
persona or just an incredible streak of
luck even the characters in universe
aren't sure
do you think he plans it all out
it just makes it up as he goes along but
what if i told you that the franchise
actually tells us the secret to captain
jack's success in the very first movie
him a room jack on an island and left
him to die but not before he'd gotten
mad with the heat though camp jack's
fanciful stories about escaping a
deserted island on the back of sea
turtles might have been a lie the whole
going mad with the heat part of it
wasn't you see captain jack is an
unpredictable force of nature not
because he's a drunk not because he's a
genius but because he's been dangerously
dehydrated for his entire life yup
dehydrated he is literally dying of
thirst so badly in fact that he's
completely boiled his own brain it
doesn't sound like that big of a deal
well it is in fact it explains all of
captain jack's behavior and mannerisms
throughout the entirety of the series
and today i'm gonna prove it to you so
first of all though i'm sure we all know
what i mean when i say that captain
jack's dehydrated how does science
actually define that phrase dehydration
occurs when you lose more fluid than you
take in and your body doesn't have
enough water to carry out its normal
functions basically when you don't drink
enough water your body has big sad and
it doesn't work well you get confused
and fatigued you're constantly thirsty
and you stop sweating which means that
your body can't cool itself off for
healthy adults that isn't that big of a
deal you can just drink some water and
you're good to go but if you can't or
don't drink water the resulting
dehydration can lead to some serious
side effects like loss of motor function
seizures kidney failure and what we're
most interested in today heat injuries
these happen when your body's been too
hot for too long and can vary from mild
cramps and a rapid pulse to heat stroke
resulting in slurred speech altered
mental states and even the loss of
consciousness when left untreated heat
stroke can seriously damage your brain
your heart your kidneys and muscles so
as you can probably tell at this point
drinking water kind of important but
when you live on a boat for huge
stretches of time getting enough water
is gonna pose some unique challenges you
see the pirates films take place in the
first half of the 1700s and irl during
that period dehydration was a huge part
of life for anyone making their living
at the sea today experts recommend that
the average man living in a temperate
climate like the caribbean consume about
3.7 liters or almost a full gallon of
water every day to stay properly
hydrated well back then on a
well-provisioned pirate ship your
allotment was literally half that amount
1.9 liters or a mere half gallon of
water a day and that's without even
mentioning the lack of proper nutrition
and hygiene on board which would lead to
food poisoning diarrhea and the rapid
spread of disease there's also the long
labor-intensive work days out in the sun
all of it depleting the water inside
their bodies all of it combining to make
the pirate's average lifespan a mere 26
years oh no oh no no pyre it's life for
me i'll pass thanks so that's the
historical context but do we actually
see any evidence in the pirates movies
that captain jack might be dehydrated
yeah quite a bit in fact in pirates 3 we
actually see that the black pearl runs
out of water while trying to escape
davey jones's locker
fire's all with the rum gone runs got
too this immediately shows us that water
on board was absolutely in the minds of
the screenwriters and while that's the
only time we hear talk of water supplies
on board if we go back to our list of
dehydration symptoms we see that jack
sparrow has them all in spades let's
start with the no sweating thing take a
look at the first ever sword fight that
jack sparrow has against will turner
jack isn't sweating at all despite the
rigorous physical activity of swimming
down to save elizabeth swan carrying her
unconscious body to shore escaping a
firing squad swinging from ropes
sprinting through the streets of a human
port city trying to break his bonds and
engaging a talented swordsman in a balmy
blacksmithery sure he's a little greasy
but not any more than he normally is in
comparison look at will from the same
scene despite entering the shop
completely dry and doing only a fraction
of the exercise that captain jack just
did he is literally dripping with sweat
halfway through the fight in fact
looking at the series in its entirety
captain jack lacked sweat the entire
time after running bent over with a
bamboo stalk strapped to his back and
escaping the cannibals the only liquid
on his face is paint and sea water after
rowing a life raft both to and from the
kraken he's likewise completely sweat
free despite trying to pull the black
pearl hard enough that he's gasping he's
still as dry as the desert around him in
pirates 4 captain jack doesn't have a
beat of sweat on him after running
through the tropical wilderness long
enough for his clothes which had been
completely soaked to dry and again this
isn't just movie magic look at other
characters they sweat jack doesn't the
long and short of all this is that his
body just doesn't have any extra water
to spare he can't sweat anymore which
means that his body can't cool off
naturally which means that he's
constantly suffering from heat stroke
side effect of that slurred speech
practically every line that he speaks
throughout the series but especially
when you get to pirates 5 is slurred
sure in some cases he's drunk but in
several others he is stone cold sober
like
here treasure to be found with the map
that no man can lead
and here shall i tell you know who
what we both know to be true i mean it's
a good thing that i can watch these
movies with closed captions because
captain jack's lines by the end of the
series are like he's gargling with rocks
in his mouth and remember when i said
that sometimes dehydration and heat
stroke can result in altered mental
states well that can manifest with some
symptoms of psychosis including
hallucinations all throughout pirates 3
captain jack both sees and talks to
several other versions of himself
including a creepy coral covered vision
of his future i miss him already he's
quite charming
earlier we see him physically
interacting with one of these
hallucinations stabbing it to intimidate
the other hallucinated selves who then
promptly disappear after finding him
will turner even makes note of captain
jack's delirious state he thinks we're a
hallucination that's not the result of
drunkenness that's the result of a brain
literally being boiled alive inside its
own skull and this contributes to other
symptoms too one of captain jack's very
visible symptoms is loss of motor
function it's long been theorized that
captain jack's general instability while
walking or standing is because of his
sea legs that he was so used to walking
on a ship bobbing at sea that dry land
tipped him off balance or maybe he's
just drunk all the time and while either
could make for a fun character detail
scientifically it actually makes more
sense that jack's dehydration impaired
his motor functions which as you watch
throughout the series just get worse
over time early in the films he simply
has trouble standing up straight or
walking without putting his arms out to
balance himself but by the time of
pirates 5 he's practically stumbling and
wobbling through every scene to the
point that he can't even jump a fence
without falling flat on his face so what
i hear you saying captain jack was
dehydrated might have been uncomfortable
but everything worked out for him and
well yes everything did work out for the
main character of a billion dollar film
franchise imagine that between the
dehydration and heat injuries affecting
his body and mind captain jack has
basically boiled his brain to the point
that his cognitive functioning has been
severely impaired when your brain
reaches 104 degrees fahrenheit or 40
degrees celsius your blood brain barrier
begins to break down this is a barrier
that separates your brain tissue from
the bloodstream allowing oxygen and
nutrients into your brain while keeping
out unwanted particles and bacteria some
studies show that you only need to
suffer one percent dehydration before
you experience up to five percent
decrease in your cognitive function even
worse a two percent decrease in brain
hydration can create short-term memory
loss and hinder your ability to quickly
complete math equations this may seem a
peculiar request because someone
explained to me this
to why i'm here i don't know where he's
coming to be
you need just a moment to clear me but
what i find scariest is that long-term
dehydration actually causes your brain
cells to shrink resulting in a sort of
brain fog a loss of mental clarity
imagine feeling groggy like you just
woke up but all the time bringing this
back around to captain jack we see
something that could very easily be
considered brain fog as early as pirates
2. when sparrow's compass can't tell
what he really wants does he want more
rum does he want the black pearl to not
work for davey jones for a hundred years
he doesn't even know and by the time of
pirates 5 this brain fog has gotten so
bad that this once sharp witty pirate
has turned into someone with difficulty
forming even a complete thought give me
the map
or i will kill
this dehydration driven brain fog could
have even impacted captain jack's
decisions as early as the first movie
when we first meet sparrow he's arriving
at port royal jamaica which at that
point had been pretty thoroughly purged
to pirates by the time the movies take
place in the 1720s they even explicitly
warn all pirates to stay away captain
jack at this point has not only been
branded as a pirate by the east india
trading company but he's also apparently
infamous enough to be recognized by the
tattoo on his arm
well well
jack sparrow isn't it and yet still he
decides to go to a port that is
notorious for killing pirates why the
only reason i can think is that port
royal is one of the closest major
caribbean points to tortuga haiti which
is where he borrowed his sinking ship
but there are options that aren't much
further away like havana cuba and nassau
in the bahamas maybe he wanted to steal
one of the navy ships but again that
seems incredibly stupid and dangerous
it's a dumb decision that would likely
only come from someone with brain fog
gem jeff's severe dehydration may also
explain why we see him drinking so much
rum ale and wine throughout the series
sure it's endearing when he says why is
the rum except i suspect that his body
has subconsciously come to rely on these
liquids for any sort of hydration that
he can find practically any liquid is
going to be better than no liquid right
but here it's just making matters worse
see though these alcohols would supply
fluid for captain jack's body they would
also be affecting his brain and
specifically his pituitary gland this
little guy in the front of the brain is
responsible for generating vasopressin a
hormone that helps prevent you from
urinating when you're dehydrated that
way your body can reabsorb the water as
opposed to losing it unfortunately for
captain jack though consuming alcohol
both decreases your ability to generate
vasopressin and weakens your ability to
help retain water thus worsening his
dehydration this then becomes a vicious
cycle camp jack working out in the heat
all day becoming dehydrated there's a
lot of water on the ship already so he
starts drinking the alcohol that he has
stashed away now he's even more
dehydrated to the point that his body
temperature is going to increase
heightening his chances for heat
exhaustion thus furthering his
dehydration and damaging his body and
mind but you know the most ironic twist
to all of this for as bad as all of this
is to his brain and body all of it might
have been truly his secret weapon
consider this by the time of pirates 5
captain jack would have been at least in
his 50s in comparison the real world
blackbeard only made it to 35 or 40.
captain kidd died at 46. jack sparrow
he's able to outlast all these other
famous pirates how i mean if you ignore
the obvious plot armor it actually boils
down to that brain fog you see his
erratic behavior caused by his boiled
brain often forces his foes into what's
called a surprise sequence a momentary
pause when someone's caught off guard by
an unusual behavior it usually
translates to people physically freezing
for about a 25th of a second followed by
confusion as their brain tries to figure
out what the heck's going on that
certainly seems to be captain jack's
effect on the british sailors when he
and will steal a ship from right under
their noses that's got to be the best
pirate i've ever seen
so it would seem or on beckett as he
escapes by shooting a cannon tied to a
rope or even on davey jones when captain
jack unexpectedly lies straight to his
face mid-sword fight
nothing would take a key
i already have the key
no you don't
oh that king
captain jack being driven mad by the
heat might have just saved his life more
times than he can count you know because
he can't count well boiled brain and all
that it's a bit funny johnny depp once
explained that he came up with a lot of
jack sparrow's personality by sitting in
a sauna cranked up as hot as it could go
he wanted to feel like his brain was
boiling that's how he envisioned this
character and in the end that character
decision may have actually wound up more
true than even he could have expected i
guess it all goes to show that some
superpowers come in the form of spider
bites some in the form of magical
candles but in jack's case his
survivability came from long-standing
dehydration i suppose what doesn't kill
ya makes you stronger but hey that's
just a theory a film theory and cuts
[Music]
you